oh hey everybody its multiple players
welcome I'm Chris waters your host and
it's Monday afternoon thank you for
finding us on our new weekly time and
we're gonna get into some risk of rain
here momentarily but first let me
introduce my fellow multiple players on
my left Rob handlery Rob hello hello
welcome to the show uh your first time
you how are you uh expecting to fair
here in the risk of rain who had a
little play through earlier um I think
I'll do subpar subpar all right like
cetera expectation I'm coming like that
Eric tang what's up seasoned veteran of
kicking my butt in video games welcome
back and marry Kish a seasoned veteran
of horrible murder betrayal I have not
played but it is raining today so I
feeling like a little feel like it's a
sign all right cool well something will
happen our resident risk of rain expert
bonito is actually out sick so he's got
like all characters a lot knows a lot of
stuff it's not here yes yeah let's play
oh we're all mine is the same character
with who's the commando and there's like
a real okay it's a tough game and it
gets tougher the longer games your Nana
Addo 23 I'm 3 i'm too I'm one are you
guys through and stuff bullets really
great why so we've got your basic don't
know let's just figure played this game
before anyone in the audience has no
idea what's going on you've got we've
got like a heavy shot which can do some
knock back we've got a spray shot which
can also just not back if you're like if
you're lucky you can do a little daddy
that's pretty much the extent of the
abilities if there's clear down on the
roll yes go to the bar a bunch of stuff
so the idea is like we go through these
areas and we try to find yeah I am giant
here we go like long they're killing
that robot I'm gonna go by this
here I don't know what it does did you
go mystery or oh you stop it off the
headstock do you level up based on who
did the final blow or do the most damage
how does that work off presumably it's
damaged but yeah you i mean you know i
don't think it's like League of Legends
where you're only guess I just forget i
think that blue bars if you are under
your help are all right so after we kill
these guys up here we're gonna we're
gonna for John word because the idea is
to get to the teleporter in each level
but once you get to a teleporter it's
like a last stand mechanic so you have
to like they start spawning in a bunch
of enemies and then once the teleporter
is ready to go jellyfish let's go down
come on owl all right strong go by that
chest go wrong you got it Oh can see it
like there's your level up thing we got
there oh yes offers to her oh oh yeah
let's do some head stomping headstall
whoa oh it does like an area damage i
think it's only you two ever it has
active overheads talking out of control
right now call us the head stampers
goods dubbers over pair of the drill
whoa hi Boudreau friend now oh alright
so watch your heads i watch your help oh
if you have them dodge out of the way of
that horrible fire one and she's got it
down dude it whatever you can what is
that thing it's a boss actually if we
beat this boss if the modern era my time
up we're right into me from purpose
classic 10 population god well we're
gonna take about you guys magra warm is
almost dead though that's a good news
everyone break it all right now I'm
losing as back together the worm got me
okay would be a real great time for
total of I am trying to lo love but i'm
also trying to live or is dead hey hey
it's too Brown and Tara baloney hello
yes we already in character all right
sweet nice when I say done oh you did do
the thing damn who's a seven right we
all survived your little son second
player ah nephew oh oh oh oh my level
smooth that oh yeah yes that's what
you're chilled enemies but now the fire
is coming out of yeah I guess that's my
new secret weapon is the fire I get like
a little fire but will fire bomber so
we're gonna talk wow that sounds like a
sound terrible experience Oh jumping in
good come on hey good work Chris on the
road I got it right fireball over no I'm
just gonna keep shooting oh I'm getting
hit jump out there I'm all right I don't
know what my goodness
I'm sorry I'd like to see you guys
function normally when everywhere you
walk fire is there thank you when you
have fire but everything much more until
I've got to work fine to this morning I
don't show my kids only a minute of
crime Wow yeah it's down to 90 second
are you gonna follow the little arrows
that are attached to our faces for their
home everyone you're welcome we all look
the same what is this guy I've got fire
but oh yeah I'll put it over here show
them show them the fire unleash violence
oh these are not look no let's just I
thought I thought I had friendly fire
but it may L mean you're Rob let's get
out here oh yes Dre me she oh my god
Oh what is it it's like a weird zipper
face creature and you're going up just
being commanded oh I got it done are you
I mean it's always about my laundry this
is making official I thought expressly
you don't have enough money oh but no I
I did it's to offer for a chance oh so
we got no Emily you got her I gambled he
go he gambled with our money I sure did
I feel like if it's over twenty dollars
you should discuss it before seventy
dollars oh well then if I can swing
coats guys were the baddest crew around
I don't know if you know that listen you
crew that's all that died really
powerful new curls Alaska was all news I
kind of miss my fire but though shall
not pass no I can't see where I am cuz
of the freaking other bars run away he's
fully me go away everything he's
following me to shields do something
with your shoes Oh will you have no
power here Oh one's dead we cookin
Harbor maps I'm gonna die loi boy I
gotta let you got the class gave me some
of the class yeah what is this guy
flappy ghost oh my god just oh he's not
having there's donkey oh nothing nice
crowd here i'm calling it no we're
killing flower girl okay killing dr.
John oh god I minute okay who's
news'matt award oh no no I can't see us
I just come back there no let's go
everyone everyone up Oh Baba to meet dr.
wise it will need hog worm it's a magnet
worm you guys what the name is right
there it couldn't be more clear oh no oh
lookit are I just love that hurt real
bad all right we ate the worm yeah
guitar guy shoot so what is usually
right you believe it's done nothing it
absolutely does know that bonus damage
sure that doesn't mean but you get all
the ladies purple gross excuse me
ancient wis check moans oh oh my god or
a mi tia oh no it's so bad it's so bad
it's so bad this is not looking good
somebody please what are you two bucks I
don't want the talks co-op I have died
here's cute this is me I have died
horribly yeah I got pie this close we're
killed by parrot that's the name of that
thing that is creepy as hell my dad dad
so ever hire you got that i don't know i
acquired the embryo irish a collation
fansa i think i was the most qualified
if I mess you know
haha frickin in deep [ __ ] yeah just
running this way Oh lay that shield down
he's always said jelly is just adding
fill out of control oh you swim around
me these the offer you life I'm aware of
the life that I'm all right so who is
player 1 I am as you have a user attack
now oh yeah yeah use their [ __ ] together
what did that really do it shoots out
these orbs like the wandering thingy guy
yeah like the wandering vagrant alright
see you guys later hey Rob good starting
out here I think my legs are good Oh God
just a scratch scratch my own what's all
these colored orb it's my room that's
what Eric can shoot out of physical body
fat what is what is come by nice view
from his aura pas sighs what would you
say the rainbow twerp do damage its
penis wait I'm scared no no no no I this
is big I I at least have the big big you
too i'm just gonna watch me yeah Oh fell
down big parents are really desi parents
are really interested in me oh wait are
we actually download black so now
instead of dead what happened where are
you guys oh it's not gonna be safe down
there anymore guys Oh fire too yeah no
don't do that what do you do your legs
you're there ok are you fine and
everything ok what is legs dinner we're
just hanging out are you just hanging
out with those weird ghost people uh
yeah Mary's just shooting couple of old
I'm shooting my college buddies am I
taking damage though I'm coming up oh
I'm gonna die oh I'm gonna die your leg
I did not ready come down g when it's
going down there having way too much fun
it's just having a ball stop going up we
have to kill these dude down here Rob
hey Rob has a ghost entourage you can
say a on the ladder edges are on the
rope just have a posse yes following
a ghost demon I really need more help
before I do this sorry guy don't worry
we got this I do right we got another
one coming in don't mom that was not the
boss must want my son's it spawned a
bone oh god a bad situation find a rope
I am very badly aah where's the Rope one
yeah I'm here to find a robe okay all
right this is this is a situation no
worm Oh over I got we hold on a reverse
Oh Mary Lee little live another lifetime
robbery from magma worms and jellies and
try it goes demons oh oh the horror oh
oh no oh oh the girls a is warning might
know what risk of rain ladies and
gentlemen it's on Steam right now it's
probably i don't know it's a couple
bucks ten at ten to fifteen dollars i
would guess what do you guys think good
times I definitely play again that was
good I liked it because we couldn't hurt
each other ha only the horrible worms
and green circles could hurt us ah this
is the news time slot for multiple
players to p.m. thank you for joining us
tomorrow morning in multiple players
normal time slot it's the Shan method at
11am and then 2 p.m. tomorrow the lobby
with good simulator and some other cool
games so pleased to be bad ass cuz
that's really hoping to get through this
luxury without a pun terrible go pawn
but that's my life now thanks for
watching folks will see you next one I
have
you